marjorie taylor green
the space laser lady
gets on the floor of the house today to
try to defend herself from
being kicked out of her committee
assignments
she says the words that
that the the things that she said those
words are in the past
well of course they're in the past you
[ __ ] [ __ ] eating [ __ ]
all words are in the past all of them
the words i'm saying right now they're
now in the past
there are no words in the future
otherwise they
wouldn't be words yet do these people
even
have a [ __ ] filter before they say
these stupid [ __ ] things
it ain't no wonder this lady believes in
jewish space lasers and
false flag school shootings it is not
it is not that hard to understand why
she believes this dumb [ __ ]
if she says something like that that
those words are in the past
of course they are all words are and you
are held accountable for the [ __ ] you
say
rather we have freedom of speech or not
it does not give you the ability to be
free from the consequences of that
speech
so today democrats plus 11
republicans and i'll get to that here in
just a [ __ ] second
plus 11 republicans
vote to strip away
the committee assignments of marjorie
taylor
greene and this is probably one of the
best
punishments that that can actually be
doled out to her here folks
because the people to punish here is not
marjorie taylor green
she is not the problem and i've said
this several times she is only a symptom
of the problem because
if the house were to actually expel this
lady
if they were to remove her from congress
like they removed her from her committee
assignments today
all that would do is allow the
republicans in georgia
to pick her q anon replacement
and we have another whack-a-doo in
congress
that would probably keep their [ __ ]
mouth shut just long enough to get on
the education committee and stay there
and actually have the ability to
possibly do some damage to our country
but now this lady is not even hardly a
full member of congress at this point
without a committee assignment because
again
these people run to have committee
assignments that's
why they become members of [ __ ]
congress in the first place
how do you think they go in court donors
well mr donor when i'm on
xyz committee i'll make sure to push
this bill through
that helps you in an xyz way
that's what happens that's how it
[ __ ] works
so of course she wants to be on a
committee of course the people in her
district in georgia
want her to be on committees
and that's what we need to focus on here
is these people down in georgia that
voted for this
[ __ ] because frankly
they need to be punished here
they sent they sent a a
psychologically disturbed person
intentionally to congress
possibly a dangerous person possibly
i'm not sure how serious she is or she
just says a lot of this [ __ ] to get
attention
a lot of these people are not serious
[ __ ] people folks they're not they're
not that [ __ ] serious
donald trump was not a he's not a
serious person
and speaking of donald trump this has a
lot to [ __ ] do with donald trump and
mitch mcconnell
what just happened tonight a lot of
people doesn't don't think that it does
but it sure as hell [ __ ] has a lot to
do
with mitch mcconnell and donald trump
having a dick contest of whose
republican party
this actually is kevin mccarthy
that weak [ __ ] runs down to
florida to mar-a-lago to kiss the ring
of donald trump
donald trump summons him down there to
make sure he's not gonna pull
these committee assignments away from
marjory taylor green his biggest [ __ ]
fan
his biggest fan that's why he likes her
jesus christ did you see the video today
of her carrying around a cardboard
cutout to her
campaign events of donald trump and then
she was
touching it not so a polite way
but that's not the point this person
is possibly disturbed she's carrying
around a cardboard cutout
of donald trump to her campaign events
that's how she was running you [ __ ]
kidding me
full-on cult member cultist
cult 45 and he loves it
well mitch mcconnell doesn't and mitch
mcconnell was the one that gave
permission to the democrats
to remove her from her committee
assignments because kevin mccarthy
wouldn't do it
and if you don't if you don't see who's
actually winning
in these institutions of who's going to
be the republican party leader then
you're not paying attention
because yesterday yesterday
there was a big push to get rid of liz
cheney well they had
they had a secret ballot
that way no one knew who voted it for
and who voted against her
and i would imagine that if we had a
secret [ __ ] ballot on the floor of
the house tonight
there would have been a whole hell of a
lot more than [ __ ] 11 republicans
that voted to remove her from her
committee assignments
for goddamn sure
the people who want her in congress less
than democrats and liberals out there
is her republican colleagues
and the only reason why leadership wants
her is because
donald trump wants her and the ruling
class and the republican party won her
the donor class
and that's not more obvious than now
because she is a fundraiser for them
that's what this q a on
[ __ ] is is white supremacist fundraising
they're fundraising with racism and
fascism that's what they're doing
and mitch mcconnell is trying to make
sure that donald trump doesn't hang on
to this republican party
that's why he called her a cancer of the
party and that
only gave paid the highway for democrats
politically here politically to remove
her from her committee assignments
what is mitch mcconnell going to say now
all you dirty democrats you got rid of
her
well two days ago she was a cancer mitch
what do you do with the cancer other
than cut it out and throw it away
so let's get real here this is not this
is not a battle about marjorie taylor
green and space lasers everyone knows
who this lady
is she's a [ __ ] fascist
racist anti-semitic nazi
that's what she is
everyone knows it including the people
who are supporting her
and that's why they're supporting her
but also be clear on this that the
republican party has a fault line in it
and marjorie taylor green
is the image of one side of that fault
line
and mitch mcconnell would like him and
liz cheney
to be the other side the other face
of that fault line and you know what
i think the republicans fighting like
this in congress
and the democrats are the ones who do
the morally right thing here
and the country stands up and cheers
because they do the morally
right thing is a win not just for the
democrats
not just for the the the republicans who
want some sanity back in their party
but the entire [ __ ] country
so [ __ ] marjorie taylor green
and anyone who looks like marjorie
taylor green